>> IT CANNOT BE THE POLICY OF A
GREAT NATION TO REWARD THOSE WHO
UNLAWFULLY ENTER ITS COUNTRY
WITH LEGAL STATUS,
SOCIAL SECURITY, WELFARE, FOOD
STAMPS, WORK PERMITS AND SO
FORTH.
HOW CAN THIS BE?
MEANWHILE THOSE WHO ENGAGE IN A
PROCESS LAWFULLY AND PATIENTLY
AND WAIT THEIR TURN ARE
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST AT EVERY
TURN.
>> Sean: THAT WAS MORE OF THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL JEFF SESSIONS
SPEAKING TODAY, CALIFORNIA ABOUT
OUR IMMIGRATION POLICY.
JOINING US NOW, UNIVISION ANCHOR
JORGE RAMOS.
WELCOME BACK, GOOD TO SEE YOUR.
>> GREAT TO SEE YOU.
SPIRIT LET'S PUT ASIDE DACA COME
OUT LET'S PUT ASIDE CHAIN
MIGRATION, LET'S PUT ASIDE THE
LOTTERY.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT CRIMINAL
ALIENS IN THE UNITED STATES.
THOSE THAT CAME HERE ILLEGALLY,
THOSE THAT COMMITTED CRIMES,
THOSE THAT ARE IMMIGRATION
OFFICERS THAT ARE TRYING TO BE
DEPORTED.
DO YOU SUPPORT THAT?
>> LET ME SAY THAT THE VAST
MAJORITY OF IMMIGRANTS IN THE
VAST MAJORITY OF DOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS ARE NOT CRIMINALS.
ALL THE REPORTS I'VE SEEN AND
THE REPORTS THAT I'VE READ
CLEARLY CONCLUDE --
>> Sean: WE CAN HAVE A
DISCUSSION -- THESE ARE
TALKING POINTS.
I WENT DOWN TO THE BORDER, I'LL
GIVE YOU FACTS.
I WAS IN HELICOPTERS, I WAS IN
BOATS AND I PASSED THROUGH A
SECURITY BRIEFING AND TEXAS WITH
RICK PERRY 642,000 CRIMES
COMMITTED BY ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
AGAINST TEXAS ALONE.
HERE'S MY QUESTION PRETTY
PUTTING ALL THOSE ISSUES ASIDE,
THOSE THAT COMMIT CRIMES IN
AMERICA, INCLUDING SOME VIOLENT
CRIMES, EVEN MURDER, THOSE
CRIMINAL ALIENS, DO YOU SUPPORTH
CRIMINAL ALIENS, DO YOU SUPPORTV
CRIMINAL ALIENS, DO YOU SUPPORTN
CRIMINAL ALIENS, DO YOU SUPPORTG
CRIMINAL ALIENS, DO YOU SUPPORTT
CRIMINAL ALIENS, DO YOU SUPPORTE
CRIMINAL ALIENS, DO YOU SUPPORT
CRIMINAL ALIENS, DO YOU SUPPORTO
CRIMINAL ALIENS, DO YOU SUPPORTE
CRIMINAL ALIENS, DO YOU SUPPORTT
CRIMINAL ALIENS, DO YOU SUPPORTI
CRIMINAL ALIENS, DO YOU SUPPORTS
COUNTRY?
>> I HAVE NO PROBLEM WITH THAT.
I'M NOT HERE TO DEFEND REAL
CRIMINALS.
WE CANNOT CRIMINALIZE THE WHOLE
IMMIGRANT POPULATION CIVILLY
BECAUSE OF WHAT IF YOU HAVE DONE
BECAUSE OF WHAT IF YOU HAVE DON
DONE.
>> Sean: DID I DO THAT?
>> THEY'RE NOT RESPONSIBLE FOR
WHAT THE SHOOTER DID IN
LAS VEGAS.
>> Sean: LET ME GIVE YOU ONE
STATISTIC.
ILLEGAL ALIENS ACCOUNTED FOR 13%
OF ALL NONIMMIGRATION RELATED
FEDERAL SENTENCES IN 2016.
THAT IS A SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER
PERCENTAGE THAN THE 3.5%
ESTIMATED POPULATION.
YOU JUST GOT DONE SAYING ALL
IMMIGRANTS DON'T COMMIT CRIMES,
I WILL AGREE WITH YOU.
THAT IS A MUCH HIGHER PERCENTAGE
THAN THE REST OF THE POPULATION.
>> I HAVE DIFFERENT NUMBERS.
I'M LOOKING AT THE MIGRATION
POLICY.
IN THIS CASE, IT HAS TO DO WITH
FAKE IDs.
THESE PERCENTAGES -- BASICALLY
MY ASSUMPTION IS THAT YOU AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP ARE
CRIMINALIZING THE IMMIGRANT
POPULATION WHO IS NOT
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE CRIMINAL
PROBLEMS WE HAVE.
>> Sean: I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT
THEM.
YOU NEVER WENT -- YOU'RE SAYING
THE PEOPLE I SAT WITH, THOSE
ENFORCEMENT, BORDER AGENTS, I
SENT IN A MEETING AND I'LL PUT
IT UP ON THE SCREEN.
>> THEY'RE RESPONSIBLE FOR
642,000 CRIMINAL OFFENSES.
>> IN TEXAS ALONE?
>> YES.
>> THERE CRIMINAL HISTORY
REFLECTS THAT THEY WERE
COMMITTED OVER 642,000 CRIMES.
>> THAT'S THE COST.
>> Sean: ARE YOU LITERALLY
SAYING TO ME THAT THEY'RE BUYING
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT.
YOU SOUND LIKE YOU DON'T CARE
ABOUT THE AMERICANS THAT ARE
VICTIMS OF CRIMES --
>> OF COURSE I DO.
I LIVE IN THIS COUNTRY, MY
CHILDREN LIVE IN THIS COUNTRY.
YOU HAVE TO PUT THOSE NUMBERS IN
PERSPECTIVE.
>> Sean: 642,000 IN
>> MOST IMMIGRANTS AND MOST
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS AND
CRIMINALS DON'T WANT TO GET IN
TROUBLE.
>> Sean: WHY ARE YOU PUTTING
WORDS IN MY MOUTH?
>> THEY DON'T WANT TO GET IN
TROUBLE WITH THE LAW.
THEY WANT TO PROSPER AND HOPE
THE REST OF AMERICA.
>> Sean: YOU ARE WRONG ON
ANOTHER POINT.
YOU'RE RIGHT, THE VAST MAJORITY
AND HAVING BEEN TO THE BORDER 13
TIMES FROM ANYWHERE TO THE RIO
GRANDE TO SAN DIEGO AND HAVING
BEEN IN THE DRUG WAREHOUSES, I
WOULD ARGUE THAT THEY WANT TO
LEAVE THE PROPERTY THAT MANY
FACE IN MEXICO AND HAVE MORE
OPPORTUNITY IN AMERICA.
I'M SAYING DO IT EASILY.
YOU'RE NOT ANSWERING MY
QUESTION.
THE 642,000 CRIMES COMMITTED
AGAINST TEXAS ALONE IN A SEVEN
YEAR PERIOD, THAT'S NOT YOUR
FAMILY.
WHERE IS YOUR SYMPATHY FOR THOSE
VICTIMS OF CRIME AND WHY SHOULD
WE TAKE THOSE THAT ARE
COMMITTING CRIMES AND TO RID
THEM TOMORROW?
>> I'M NOT HERE TO DEFEND THE
REAL CRIMINALS.
I'M NOT HERE TO DEFEND REAL
CRIMINALS.
IF YOU PUT THOSE NUMBERS --
>> Sean: IF YOU COME HERE
ILLEGALLY, YOU ARE A CRIMINAL.
>> YOU DON'T TELL YOUR AUDIENCE
THE TRUTH, THE FACTS, THAT
IMMIGRANTS ARE LESS LIKELY TO BE
CRIMINALS --
>> Sean: THAT'S NOT ACCURATE.
ADDRESS KATE STANLEY'S FAMILY.
THERE ARE A LOT OF FAMILIES THAT
SADLY HAVE BEEN VICTIMIZED BY
PEOPLE HERE ILLEGALLY THAT
COMMIT MORE CRIMES.
WHAT YOU SAY TO HER FAMILY?
>> I CANNOT EVEN IMAGINE WHAT
THEY'RE FEELING.
I CANNOT EVEN THINK ABOUT THAT.
THERE IS NO EXCUSE FOR THAT.
AGAIN, IF YOU SAY THAT ALL
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS OUR
RESPONSE WILL FOR THESE CRIMES
BUT --
>> Sean: NOBODY'S SAYING THAT.
I'M NOT INFERRING.
I SPEAK VERY DIRECTLY.
I AM SAYING TO THE MAYOR OF
OAKLAND, STOP AIDING AND
ABETTING CRIMINALS THAT
COMMITTED MORE CRIMES AND I
THINK YOU SHOULD WANT THAT
MIRROR TO DO THE SAME.
>> WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
SANCTUARY CITIES.
SANCTUARY CITIES ARE SAYING NO
AND CALIFORNIA IS SAYING NO.
>> Sean: WE HAVE LOST THAT
OUGHT TO BE OBEYED.
ABSOLUTELY.
YOU DON'T BELIEVE IN OUR LAW.
>> I DO, BUT SOMEBODY HAS TO
HELP IMMIGRANTS.
AND SECOND, THIS POLICY
ESTABLISHED BY PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND HIS ADMINISTRATION IS --
>> Sean: PRESIDENT TRUMP
SUPPORTED DACA.
>> LET'S NOT FORGET THAT THE
PERSON WHO KILLED DACA --
>> Sean: HE WAS THE ONE -- LET
ME ASK A QUESTION.
WE GO DOWN WITH ME INTO A TOWN
HALL IN TEXAS AND WILL INVITE
THE 642,000 FAMILIES OF THOSE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO COME THAT
WERE VICTIMS OF CRIME AND LISTEN
TO THEIR STORIES?
WILL YOU COME?
>> I'LL GO WITH YOU AND THEN
BUILD A SITE WHO WILL ATTEND
THAT SHOW.
THIS CONVERSATION IS INTERESTING
AND I APPRECIATE YOU GIVING ME